yeah I was a I'll still buzzing off of
the UFC event from like two weeks ago
okay that was first of man amanda Nunez
everyone's talked about her like to
death I'm sure but holy [ __ ] that girl
what happened she beat up so she beat
the [ __ ] out of Ronda Rousey mm-hmm like
decisively okay you know and she took
her career apart and then so she was
supposed to fight cyborg who which is a
robot
crazy-ass name right it's awesome yeah
she beat all the girls so that she had
to fight a robot yeah so cyborg has been
like long regarded as like one of the
best if not the best female MMA fighter
and and she trucks anyone she fights as
she walks the room and so everyone was
like okay Amanda Nunez is the best
cyborg is the best this is the fight to
make and they're supposed to fight but
then Nunez got sick and then Dana I was
saying like how she's not real champion
this and that and she was the underdog
plus 220 everyone thought that means
like you're gonna [ __ ] get your ass
beat okay I mean it's pretty standard
but it's pretty wide gap hmm you know so
you bet 100 bucks you to 1 to 20 on her
okay so she gets in there dog and it
only took like 10 to 12 punches and she
knocks cyborgs lights out really yeah
you know the face you make when you're
talking to someone and then you forget
if you left the stove on that's the face
cyborg made like right before going down
she was like she's like in the fights
like okay [ __ ] slip slip did I lock the
house and then just boom boom boom boom
and then she's done gone yeah and amanda
has this crate like her arms are super
long but she has this crazy like like
she comes over the top and she like
hooks her arm it looks like a [ __ ]
like a scythe and she just [ __ ] bang
just hooks it into your face and she
clocked her in one of those I was like
ah first round
this at first round she knocked her out
first round yeah that's crazy the same
thing with Ronda Rousey Wow
yeah so she's a beat she's like she's
the best fighter of all time oh I mean
there's it's gonna be a thing a minute
before there's any woman who can compete
with that girl
that's dope yeah she she's gonna have to
actually start fighting robots I think
she will because there's nothing left I
don't think anyone could be a challenge
for her whooping that ass
the Floyd Mayweather one was so funny
[Laughter]
that even like hear about it and then I
saw like a random Twitter moment about
her or some [ __ ] yeah it was like um so
the dry I talked about that a little bit
like a few episodes ago I was base like
rising or risen I forget how to
pronounce it it's like a Japanese League
slash promotion and didn't you say the
fight wasn't actually gonna happen so it
was like it was like this weird thing
where basically it looked like they were
trying to do something they've done
before where like Japanese league will
get a boxer to come over and then they
like get the rules weird and then last
minute they're like oh this is a public
event and it's basically like they're
trying to like hoodwink them into like
getting their ass whooped by kickboxer
in front of like a bunch of people okay
basically too you know so they're trying
to do a similar thing where they're
they're trying to get Mayweather knocked
out in their promotion or like hurt to
like show one that Mayweather isn't the
best of all time and to it's like on
their you know on their mat and they'd
love nothing more than Mayweather to go
down with like their [ __ ] fight promo
behind him so and - and Mayweather knew
this he figured it out so he said no
this is either gonna be a exhibition
match or there's no the you know there's
no fight and it's gonna be a boxing
match he's not gonna get to kick me
there are no elbows there's none of that
[ __ ] it's boxing and then they say okay
so they you know they he gets the rules
where he wants it to be which he should
and so it was a live streamed event and
it wasn't like an official fight so went
on either of their records there's only
three rounds and it didn't even get
there because that kid got his ass
handed to him oh my god I was
embarrassing do you watch the replay
yeah I did I was like those punches that
Mayweather hit him with his [ __ ] head
shot out like a cannon yeah it's just
what he was doing that face yeah doing
that [ __ ] just talking to his wife in
the crowd yeah honey we dropped the dog
off at the Walker right hey guys as
whoop that was cool any it's like I felt
bad laughing man but it's like yeah yeah
are you gonna take that fight
[Music]